it's on President Trump not sitting back
quietly while his former FBI director
disparages him to the media and to
readers of his new tell-all book a
higher loyalty Comey hurls all kinds of
accusations about the president
comparing him to a mob boss who is quote
unethical and untethered to truth in a
clip just released he also discusses the
infamous dossier did you tell him that
the Steele dossier had been financed by
his political opponents no I didn't I
don't think I used the term steel
dossier I just talked about additional
material but did he have a right to know
that that had been financed by his
political opponents I don't know the
answer to that it wasn't necessary for
my goal which is to alert him that we
had this information did you tell him
you thought it wasn't true or he didn't
know if it was true or not
I never said I don't believe it because
I couldn't say one way or another
did you believe his denial I honestly
never thought these words would come out
of my mouth but I don't know whether the
current president nighted states with
with prostitutes peeing on each other in
Moscow in 2013 it's possible mr. Trump
had some words of his own this morning
calling call me a proven leaker and liar
a weak and untruthful slimeball who was
a terrible director of the FBI he says
it was his great honor to fire Comey
well Sarah Sanders was just asked about
that attack on the former FBI director
he isn't all that a bit unbecoming of
the presidency of this White House to go
after him in such a personal way like
that I think it's unbecoming for the
person that is supposed to be the top
law enforcement official in the United
States the person that is supposed to
protect the people of this country to
lie and leak classified information
certainly to falsified documents I
didn't encourage Jim Comey to go out and
do a PR campaign Congress has asked Jim
Comey to come and testify multiple times
of which he's denied being able to do
yet he found time to see
down with George Stephanopoulos for five
hours okay so obviously some rough stuff
there in terms of going back and forth
people thought this book was going to be
quite explosive you saw this start out
this morning with the president tweeting
you saw the reaction on social media and
online so we take you around the table
and take reflections Greg this is a deep
throat it's more like Gossip Girl I mean
the white half-moons under his eyes I
mean that's a revolution of Revelation
we noticed that every time he's talking
because he's usually out on the golf
course also I love that part where he
like Comey is in this eternal state of
surprise or emotional anguish he's
always conflicted and things are
bothering him and how do I deal with
this and then this happens is always the
world is always happening to him right
and he's just the everyman the Jimmy
Stewart he said that when he met Trump
he said it reminded him of a mafia boss
as if that's a problem I mean I mean if
that's a problem when you're dealing
with North Korea and Putin I think
America might see that as a plus I much
rather have I guess a mafia boss than a
grad student TA mm-hmm so I think that
that's like that's your revelation it's
a very emotional book it's like an it's
a tell-all by an ex looking forward to
one of those he's doing through the
whole like poetry where it's another yes
what where are we going here with this
right exactly
Dana what do you think in terms of kind
of the rollout for this from a
communications perspective call me first
well I think it's textbook and he
they've been pitching this books ever
since he got the advance to write it and
so the pre-orders were probably off the
charts he's going to be the darling of
the media for the next several days but
I do think when he's talking about the
mafia boss
it's not about foreign policy he's
talking about the demands for loyalty
from people that work in the government
and that's what Comey says led to his
being fired because he wasn't going to
be that person for right I like the
whole package you know if that's part of
being a mafia boss so it's okay okay all
right well that's one point of view
holder then we would have criticized my
dick criticized holder for not
aggressive again and being independent
enough in defending the president when
he didn't deserve it but I guess it
comes down to one fact that there's a
certain kind of person who runs for
president Trump isn't that person no
matter how hard you want him to be Mitt
Romney or Al Gore yes he did it but he
did it without the purity test all
politicians know how to fake Wow
yeah yeah he's definitely acts like a
mob boss he's not a mob boss but I think
Comey a little sensitive to pick up with
what Gregg said he reminds me of the kid
that like didn't really have the stomach
to confront someone face to face and
then later ran back and scribbled it
down in his little diary and wrote it in
his little notepad and now he's just
trying to profit ear off of it like most
people try to profit off the president I
think he's really diminished the
credibility of the FBI he botched two
investigations the Hillary and the Trump
investigation and he's now really
muddying the waters with the Muller
investigation
he's a critical witness in this whole
thing I remember he gave me he's one of
the obstruction of justice centerpieces
for this and he's running his mouth and
he's writing tell-alls the way he talks
about the dossier is disturbing too
because this dossier was paid for by
Hillary yet he didn't feel the need to
tell the president-elect that his
biggest nemesis was the one that paid
for it and got it out in front of
everything that seems to be a critical
piece of information I thought George
Stephanopoulos did a really nice job
asking about that the whole thing about
he is a liar and a leaker you can't
really discount that - he testified
under oath that he never leaks yet he
leaked this memo to his buddy
and then it hit the press so he is a
liar and a leaker that's the truth I
don't think this guy he's supposed to be
a lawman this and you know he sounds
like a schoolgirl yeah is the bottom
line he's emotional he's socially
awkward he can't even be alone with the
president it's it's how weird is that
he's a school I'm not to diminish school
girls he sounds
essentially your little child that is
not really who I would think would be
the one the leading lawman in the
country the tough guy to take people
down you have to be gender specific yes
be gender neutral right the Jim Comey
entire boy how's that Jim Comey is not a
perfect advocate for Democrats or
Republicans my party hates what he did
to Hillary Clinton and reopening the
investigation and not telling the public
about the Trump investigation so I'm not
going to defend Jim Comey on on his face
but I will say the book fits into a
narrative about the president and the
president's response underscores some of
what Jim Comey is saying that he's ego
driven that the president's ego driven
he's narcissistic I mean the response
from the president is like a schoolyard
bully if you want to continue with your
analogy here
so look what matters most is not this
media blitz it's going to go on for a
couple days it's Bob Muller and you're
right that Jim Comey is a key player in
there but this book will will be
interesting in gossipy what Bob Muller
finds about Jim Comey's role and
obstruction is what will matter in the
end here
look this is pretty strong language when
you think about it you know for the
former head of the FBI to say the
president is unethical and untethered to
truth and institutional values that is
making a very strong statement but then
again he did get fired by him so the
problem is you're gonna have a situation
like this Dana where obviously the
relationship between the two was fraught
and maybe the you know truths of some I
think that the book is going to
reinforce any preconceived notion that
you have about President Trump or Jim
Comey that if you're a Democrat who want
things that he did this for Hillary
Clinton and also remember I think we
didn't even bring this up that he says
that he thought Hillary Clinton was
going to win therefore that's why he
decided to reveal it so that she
wouldn't look like an illegitimate
president and then but if you're the
Trump camp if you're in the Hillary camp
thing oh really so you did that to you
and you protected president Trump and
you didn't tell President Chirac was
under investigation definitely
Democrats have a lot to be mad about to
that point good to that point he he
wouldn't have done it if it was closed
he only did it because he thought it
wasn't closed so his decision was purely
political right and he waited a month
until they released that to the public
this is a man who was supposed to be you
know the head of the FBI leading the the
best and brightest and now look in the
aftermath of what has occurred in terms
of Comey the investigations the
collusion that has come out in terms of
obstruction page and what they were up
to that's really doesn't damage and this
was under his leadership to the American
conception of it
look the fine FBI officers and men and
women that I have worked with throughout
my career I have the utmost respect they
work very hard for very little money
this is not good or healthy as a country
to have this it seems to me when I read
this like poetry and the I thing it
seems like Shakespeare in the Park
but you know FBI president let's get it
together well in the National Review Jim
Garrity wrote a really good piece he
mentioned a lot of X FBI officials who
have had long careers there and their
people defended James Comey in the
beginning they didn't like the way he
was fired by the President and now
they're coming out and they're saying
listen it's always about Jim Comey the
guy's a celebrity always wants the
spotlight on him and we gave him the
benefit of the doubt in the beginning
but now it's looking like it's an ego
play and they don't like that they like
the focus on the FBI delivering results
not the politicization of the FBI and
unfortunately that's what's happened
here well but they're also that he kept
the personal notes and then there was
the allegations of leaked information to
the New York Times and when I look at
this as a prosecutor I said okay wait a
second what's going on here with respect
to these nodes where are they is he
going to be compelled to approve or word
what's going on because to me that's
undermines kind of the American
sensibility of fairness and
appropriateness in terms of what what is
he doing there was it because he was
gonna write a book or do something I
don't know
well and I think going back to what I
said earlier just because Jim Comey is
an imperfect
cinge er yeah doesn't mean some of the
message is in to true FairPoint so I
think I agree with everything you just
said he has not
you know acquitted himself perfectly
here we can't discard everything he's
saying because of that he did make a lot
of serious allegations as you pointed
out about the president being a liar and
untethered to the truth and unethical I
haven't read the whole book but of
what's leaked out so far he has not
pointed to one specific thing where the
president has outright lied where the
president has done something unethical
except for the smears comparing him to a
mob boss or you know saying he
intimidated me which I don't even know
what that means or the FBI director
someone shouldn't intimidate there is
testimony as well and for in terms of in
front of congressional committees that
was called into question but anyway it's
a fascinating to look at and discuss you
know as a lawyer and where the
investigation going so let's see